this idea of social distancing measures
isn't unique to Washington State in fact
the director of the National Institute
of Allergy and Infectious Diseases
that's dr. Anthony foul she spoke about
it with our dr. Jon LaPook last night
for 60 minutes in China millions are
quarantined is that where we're headed
here in the United States I don't
imagine that the degree of the draconian
nature of what the Chinese did would
ever be either feasible applicable
doable or whatever you want to call it
in the United States I don't think you
could do that the idea of social
distancing yeah I mean obviously that's
something that will be seriously
considered depending upon where we are
in a particular region of the country
and dr. Jon LaPook joins us now doctor
good morning so if we're not going full
quarantine we're gonna do social
distancing what is that exactly it's
just trying to keep yourself away from
other people especially large crowds
schools you know what a corporations do
should you be doing teleconferencing and
things like this we know from past
epidemics including the 1918 huge flu
epidemic that it kind of works you know
different cities that did a lot of
social distancing did better than those
that didn't in your interview with dr.
Fauci he says quarantines are not doable
in this country
he doesn't say they're not necessarily
appropriate right and if you see in
China you know there is a leveling off
of cases you know it's a big country so
it may be effective in as dr. pouchy
told me before this is a huge never been
done on the scale that it was done in
China where tens of millions of people
are in quarantine so are we past the
point of containment and what should we
be doing at this point you know I think
when we have the millions of test kits
that dr. Fauci said we need we'll get a
better idea we get our arms around
exactly how widespread it is and and the
chances are that it's out much more
widely than we think it is one that
we've documented so then we're talking
about sort of logical steps and I think
social distancing makes a lot of
difference it makes a lot of sense and
and I think corporations have to start
thinking about things like okay how do
we protect our most vulnerable
populations so if you have people in
your corporation for example who are
immunosuppressed who have
these chronic diseases that are serious
that could increase your chances of
getting serious disease maybe consider
having them at home working from home
paid paid because there's a financial
hit and also it shouldn't count towards
sick days right and so we need to start
thinking about these things as a society
and it can't just be well I'm gonna do
this and another better person can do
that we need national leadership to say
okay here's an algorithm here's a way of
logically thinking about if you are in
that vulnerable population what should
you be doing well what I'm telling my
patients is you know I think you should
use your common sense you can't
obviously hermetically seal yourself but
I would stay away from large crowds if I
had somebody who's immunocompromised
this is not the time to go to the
theater this is not the time to do
things where you could possibly be
exposed then as Tony Fowey said this is
certainly not the time to go on a cruise
ship people do to protect themselves
beyond washing hands and this social
distancing technique you know I don't
want to minimize the social distancing
and I don't want to minimize the washing
hands so I was just reading something
that said in past epidemics and past flu
epidemics washing your hands I know it
sounds so simple it can make a huge
difference it could decrease the amount
of deaths and infections dramatically so
that's something that people should do
we know how its spread which for the
most part by droplets right so don't
think magically usually within about six
feet of somebody you're gonna get it and
I would say if you want to do something
actually that we're not talking about
sleep we know that sleep improves your
immune system I just have to point out
that Germany has about twice as many
cases as the US and only 20 we have 21
deaths they have zero what are they
doing right well remember that we
haven't done enough testing here so when
you think about the mortality rate that
you're hearing what's the true
denominator if it turns out that it's a
lot more people out there that have this
infection than we realize it then the
mortality rate is lower it's a lot lower
so we still don't have our arms around
this that's the big problem is we don't
really know what we're doing hits are
crucial right now we're kind of flying
blind as a physician somebody has a
sniffle they have a cough what is it I
want to be able to test them so I need
the tools of the trade all right John
thank you